do you really believe you could beat me
in a straight-up old-fashioned fistfight
let me tell you something me and you
one-on-one
no one else around I will beat your ass
like a Cherokee drum maybe one day we'll
find out oh you better hope that day
never comes
don't we get back through so just a
malfunction keep that just a malfunction
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there's still onus these guys are taking
this person you were only supposed to
create a diversion Roman that was
complete destruction that you want for
me I'm Roman Pearce man it's what I do
phase two phase two what's phase two
pounds away you know what I like about
you dawn
you're a genuine outlaw but you're his
family the hell of a job brother when we
get back to the base beers on me he's
about to go up against the only thing
they can't handle you did you ever think
you'd betray your family the way you did
today Dominic Toretto
just turned on us oh well well do you
look at that I don't know why he's doing
this
that wasn't dumb she's the very
definition of high-tech terrorism and
now she's working with your guy I think
I found my team this should be
interesting
[Music]
we're like that
ouch
this is impossible which is why they
gonna need a little help I will beat you
like a Cherokee drum we about to go oh
it took longer than I expected
if you got a catch dog you guys are
gonna work together surprise I just fell
in love I'll be waiting for this we got
a tank this row
here they come
I don't know if the old Dom is in there
I don't give a damn I'm taking you down
so right over let's play
[Music]
plant is shooting at me I don't know
maybe because you're a lorries
lamborghini chance
[Music]
we go BOTS Blasco we are about to go
[Music]
oh [ __ ] we're gonna need a bigger truck
[Music]
dumb you're gonna turn your back on
family
[Music]
both still
adios Toretto
okay Buster let's see if this works
it's impossible
[Applause]
Dominic Toretto just turned on us you're
gonna work for me there's only one team
in the world it could find off and
they're standing right in front of me
it's impossible we're gonna have to be
damn fast
yeah I just don't give up you there
[Music]
I'll take a wheel
you gotta pay person be billing IMAX let
me ask you something um what's the best
thing in your life family no it's not
but if you're being honest it's the ten
seconds between start and finish when
you're not thinking about anything no
family
no obligations just you being free
I gotta tell you this whole saving the
world Robin Hood nonsense you've been
doing recently it's not you bu you are
why I live only a quarter-mile at a time
when you can live your whole life that
way
don't you're gonna turn your back on
family
[Music]
I've got no choice you turn the most
important person in my universe against
me it only takes one poet for you to
lose everything
you love me and you are not gonna shoot
the real Don is in there somewhere
let's if you gotta pursue
the fan base of this franchise it is
unlike anything I've ever seen you have
fans around the world the way that we
have the motivation and inspiration is
beyond your wildest imagination and fans
who are incredibly loyal but they're
also very very vocal you know you listen
to the audience we feel the weight of
that and because of that we move forward
what we wanted to do was capitalize off
of what the sagas represented for the
last two decades and attempt to
challenging a hell of a job brother
when we get back to the base beers on me
only way we're really going to be able
to continue this story was to expose the
darker more dangerous side to Dom
Toretto and that's what we have to do
it's too right for me get out of here
Dominic Toretto just turned on us this
is a completely different story than you
ever experienced in the fast franchise
Dom is always about them and with this
storyline he's going up against the team
and he's going up against the family
what better way to turn this entire
franchise on his head and to do
something like that did you ever think
you'd betray your family the way you did
today they'd be throwing the element of
Charlie's thrown I love that Charlize is
in this movie she really set the tone
she's definitely the fiercest villain
the franchise has ever seen it's a whole
new start to the franchise and that's
what we continue to do is reinvent
ourselves that's all made out take the
wheel what
this is crazy
alright you get style points for that
one maybe the Fuhrer is going to broken
his minds
blow people's minds
fire
on your ass
[Music]
Dominic Toretto
just went rogue you gonna turn your back
on family
[Music]
I'm taking you down so write out one
play like that
if you gotta catch da you're gonna need
a little help you want to tell me why
you just put me in a room with this
criminal nothing that tight t-shirts cut
off the circulation he'll Brian you
should get bigger size you guys are
gonna work together love to go cat five
miles away and just don't give up today
Oh
I don't want to be swimming oh I got
your roller I live my life a quarter
mile at a time
nothing else matters for those 10
seconds or less
I'm free
[Music]
the open road could take you anywhere to
friends to family we know he's an
O'Conner but he's also a Tyrell to law
for adventure let's do it to see
something new
what do you mean drift just to come back
home again honestly though
the fastener fears saga has explored the
endless possibility of the open road
from the street just outside downtown
Los Angeles we've taken you to Miami
we've taken you to Tokyo the Dominican
Republic Rio
Londyn Abu Dhabi and now our name is
known all over the world one last ride
we have raced for Speed race for honor -
Don was had you greens our city's tumble
down mountains and even dropped out of
the sky but no matter how our adventures
grow fast and furious is always about
one very important thing
family the most important thing in life
always be the people in this room salute
me famiglia
our family of characters do everything
for each other and with each other for
the millions who make up our global
family advance we push ourselves to go
further and do better time after time
right along we never ride alone we never
ride alone this time it ain't just about
being fast now we embark on our next
chapter our family will be challenged
like never before
by adversaries who show no mercy testing
that farm that has always kept us
together
and most ambitious most entertaining
fastest and most furious Rania
is fast and furious wherever you go like
you ride I ride promise promise
Dominic Toretto just turned on us don't
give up on her
you chose to ban I got no choice
the real DOM is in there somewhere what
you love me and you are not gonna shoot
me
it's kinda busy Domon wedding the love
is so deep between these two think
they're kindred spirits they represent
that ideal love and I think that that
connection has helped well all of the
films just kind of keep a heart
underneath all of the action in the
chaos walk-ins are good I don't want you
around when they catch up to me I think
that what Letty admires about Dom this
is independence is free spirited gusto
for life no that's not my style I got a
write a diary how good sis riderless Dom
and Letty have had from the beginning
unshakeable understanding that they're
soul mates
well the best seems in fast secures the
fourth chapter is when DOM is explaining
teaches all who this girl was
and have those kind of eyes and look
right to the good in someone you must
have loved her very much
[Music]
they don't pick around
I got Toretto it's like a new
relationship for you know DOM and Elena
these guys criminal
you're under arrest she doesn't see that
in him
[Music]
they're in exactly the same situation
DOM and Elena because they both lost
their love of their lives
fake they feel like they may be the only
people that can understand one another
she's so special to you I never thought
anyone could understand how much but you
do
domina Lena not together they live in
the Canary Islands we know that
Michelle's alive but now is a conflict
for Dawn was like what she gonna do it
it's the one thing that could have
crippled DOM and made him second-guess
everything its Letty isn't it I think
she's really strong to be able to say it
go and do whatever you have to do it I
would go has to go on a prayer let her
she very well may be a lot we've watched
Dom have to hold on to his conviction
that she loved him letting its woman
shooting you and he's trying to tell all
his buddies she loves me and did the
Letty we once knew is gone you don't
turn your back on them even when they do
they've been together through hell and
back it's rare to see a combination like
that screams these two characters are so
electrifying together on screen
how's that honeymoon going DOM
you see that's a funny thing about fate
it's cunning can bring you beautiful
things and it can also bring you moments
like this you see your team is about to
go up against the only thing they can't
handle what's up you
I team listen up
this crews about family but the game has
changed now
[Music]
Dominic Toretto just went rogue you're
gonna turn your back on family I know it
looks bad don't give up on I'm so easy
you've only got one chance to make this
family whole again
don't do this dawn you ready
one thing I can guarantee no one's ready
for this she's the very definition of AI
tech terrorism there's thousands of cars
in the city and now they're all mine now
I know what it feels like to be every
cop ever chasing us
[Music]
wait-wait-wait
Oh
Londyn Abu Dhabi Cuba our paths have
crossed before dawn you just didn't know
it
I think I need to remind you why you
chose to be here I got no choice
if you gotta catch Dom you got me little
help you want to tell me why you just
put me in a room with this team crumpets
eatin criminal nothin that tight
t-shirts cut off the circulation he'll
Brian you should get bigger so nice you
guys are gonna work together love to
I've been waiting for this we got a tank
now slots are whoa baby
[Music]
you just don't give up do they you
thought this was gonna be a street fight
hey talk it out
take the wheel what
this is crazy alright you get style
points for that one I don't know why
you're doing this but I know one thing
you love me
[Music]
fire
[Music]
no one's ready for this
this is a new chapter in the fast saga
and these are challenges that these
actors have never been through before
and to be able to mix it up with them
creatively was fantastic
ah well he really needed was a director
that was going to be able to expose a
more dangerous and deadlier side - Dom
Toretto I want to be challenged as a
filmmaker so looking at a movie this
massive that takes place around the
world that's a huge challenge for me hey
good I love F Gary brings a different
flavor to the box
he's definitely pushing up the bar on
the cars
just some love when it comes to the cars
I am a detail freak I'm talking about
rim choices rim colors tired choices
interior colors I mean I just love cars
he feels very strongly about things
being realistic and real a fights to to
nail for that stuff and he's got a very
edgy way that you shoot ray to be
trusted with the task of bringing this
to the big screen was just it's an honor
[Music]
what is up guys
I'm Sasha pearl raver and we are here in
the middle of Times Square for the
takeover for the fate of the furious I
never in a million years dreamed that
the day would come that not only would I
feel so proud of a movie but the trailer
of a movie just the trailer of a movie
would shut down all the Times Square I
can't wait
[Music]
we always want to make sure that if
we're gonna deliver a movie like this at
this size of the magnitude you want to
do a big you want to do a big you want
to do it cool we bought out the fans and
fans here there's fans inside by the
fans waiting outside for the trailer so
it's just big cool fun and epic we are
making history right here right now we
did it for you we love y'all I'll always
remember why I'm here so thank you
[Music]
Dominic Toretto just went rogue you're
gonna turn your back on family